we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p i would love to hear from you
if you have any
message for me hopefully a polite one uh
you can leave it at 219 to david p
here's a great question about something
we've touched on a little bit before but
it's particularly relevant now
in the conversations about the january 6
riots why are some in the media
referring to these right-wing terrorists
as militia members take a listen
yes i'm just wondering why the media
continues to call
these right-wing terrorist groups
militia
they are actually vigilantes right most
media people are really always
very critical about how they use words
vigilantes are people who
take the law into their own hands and
that's what they're they're not militia
and they want to sound they want to call
themselves militia
just to sound more legitimate of course
this has been something we've talked
about for a long time
many of these groups these sovereign
citizen groups and these anti-government
groups and those who
um those who come out to oppose antifa
sometimes with violence or whatever the
case may be and by the way that's not me
endorsing violence from anybody to be to
be very clear
they want to be called militia militia
sounds sort of like an unofficial
military battalion or platoon or
whatever the case may be
you're talking about vigilantes who are
taking the law into their own hands um
in in violation of the law you're
talking in many cases when they actually
go out and commit
acts of whatever we're talking about
terrorism here and i think the media
corporate media would be much more
accurate if they were using that term
rather than militia at minimum say
self-described militia
which is not actually a real thing in
terms of legally binding or
conferring any kind of rights or or
privileges to be vigilantes this is
something that they've dubbed themselves
it's extrajudicial it's not recognized
by the law in any way shape or form
it would be great if that was made more
clear on a regular basis
very astutely pointing that out in the
voicemail call
if you have a message for me 219
to david p on the bonus show today
the colonial pipeline ceo now admits
to authorizing a greater than 4 million
dollar
ransomware payment to get the pipeline
flowing again incredible um chicago
mayor
lightfoot says she will only be giving
one-on-one interviews
uh-oh to journalists of color
we will weigh in on that and the
governor of texas greg abbott has now
signed into law one of the most
restrictive
abortion bills in the country which
would ban abortion
as early as six weeks we will talk about
whether that will hold legally and much
much more on today's bonus show
please get access to the bonus show this
is my please clap moment
please get access sign up at
joinpackman.com
make a pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and then you will be
brought right into the world of the
award-winning
world-famous bonus show i will be joined
by producer pat
and i will see you then